everybody knows deadpool has a mutant
healing factor that's kind of this thing
it's no secret that he's aware he's a
fictional character either breaking the
fourth wall is what set deadpool apart
from all those other grizzled bulky
pouch wearing 90s tough guys and made
him into the wisecracking antihero he is
today but the marvel universe is filled
with mutants who can heal themselves
like Wolverine Sabretooth mystique and
x-23 just to name a few and Wade Wilson
needs more than just a speedy recovery
to stay ahead of his mutant cohorts
thankfully Deadpool has many other
tricks up his sleeve here are a few
master of disguise Deadpool is tough
funny and charming but let's face it
he's not exactly a looker the
experimental surgery that gave Wade
Wilson his regenerative powers also
kicked his cancer into overdrive and
while the procedure kept tumors from
ravaging his body it didn't keep them
from growing all over his face as a
result Deadpool looks like well like a
testicle of teeth his words not ours
anyway he understandably prefers not to
show his face in public so when he's on
the job that isn't much of a problem put
a mask over that gruesome mug and nobody
can tell the difference but it's a town
he has to get creative in the comics
Deadpool uses a holographic image
inducer and disguises to change his
appearance and wander around incognito
Deadpool also employs the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles proven low-tech disguise i
hat in a trench coat and the comforting
knowledge that in new york city a tumor
infested weirdo probably won't be the
weirdest thing you'll see wandering the
streets teleportation
Deadpool can't fly and doesn't have
super speed so what's the busy mercenary
to do when he has to get somewhere in a
hurry in the movie he takes a taxi but
that doesn't make for very exciting
comics and as the film version of
Deadpool proves Wade's not always great
at keeping track of its belongings yep
the guns were in that taxi as a result
Deadpool has used a number of
teleportation devices to get around
quickly in the comics in the early
issues of Deadpool he has a device
tucked away in one of his many pouches
which allows him to zip around with ease
then he even biologically combined with
cable for a while in the cable and
Deadpool series due to a crazy virus
which allowed him to share cables
teleportation tech hard to get drunk
Deadpool's healing factor is pretty
handy it stops cancer and cures
decapitation it lets them walk away from
fights with creatures like the Hulk and
it kicks his metabolism into overdrive
that's right no matter how much he eats
Deadpool
that's all good news when you're
fighting supervillains but it isn't so
useful when you want to get absolutely
hammered and let's face it weight is the
kind of guy who could use a drink every
now and then but Deadpool can't get
drunk
he just needs a lot of alcohol to make
it happen and Deadpool number 12 Wade
spends an entire day and night drinking
before he's even slightly buzzed in
Deadpool number 7 a villain pays
Deadpool to make Ironman drunk but
instead of forcing Tony Stark off the
wagon
Deadpool takes care of business himself
Wade clock start with a liquor bottle
then straps into the Ironman armor but
not before downing an entire sack full
of stolen booze that fulfills waved
contract
Ironman had to get plastered not Tony
and best of all
Deadpool doesn't even have a hangover
when he wakes up now that's a superpower
superhuman strength Deadpool is able to
lift between eight hundred fifty
thousand pounds but you wouldn't know it
just by looking at him while
super-strength is one of Deadpool as
many powers you rarely see him lifting
heavy objects and the only time Wade
seems to make use of his enhanced
abilities is when he goes toe-to-toe
with heavyweights like the Hulk and the
juggernaut still every once in a while
somebody hints that Deadpool is a lot
stronger than he seems
during his earliest appearances you went
toe-to-toe with some of Marvel's
strongest characters in x-force number
11 shatter star a warrior from the mojo
versed with super strength called
Deadpool his equal right before Deadpool
knocks him out cold and x-force number
15 wait is powerful enough to kick evils
head through a stone wall Deadpool super
strength is made of fundin Li clear in
cable and Deadpool number 13 paji Ben
Barrett one of the world's most deadly
terrorists is murdered and Deadpool
wants to solve the case as Deadpool
gathers clues the medical examiner
conclude that Barrett was choked by an
adult male using just two fingers in
fact the murderer actually squeezed too
hard accidentally snapping Barrett's
neck mid killing a feat that would
require superhuman strength at the same
time Deadpool discovers that he's the
murderer he just can't immediately
remember why he did it because you know
comics cursed to be immortal
Thanos one of the biggest Bad's in a
galaxy full of big bads has the hots for
death as in the literal personification
of mortality and he'll do practically
anything to prove it so as you can
imagine Thanos isn't exactly thrilled
when death and Deadpool strike up a
relationship in Deadpool death annual 98
Wade first meets Thanos would be gal-pal
when he's stuck in the department k
medical facility undergoing the
treatments that will eventually turn him
into Deadpool thanks to his cancer in
the government's
and suede is very very close to dying
and death uses her feminine wiles to try
and convince way to finish the job
however wage newfound healing powers and
a reluctant sense of heroism foil as
best attempts at suicide by super
villain and the couple is forced apart
later to keep Deadpool away from death
Thanos puts a curse on Wade that brings
him back to life whenever he dies and
will keep him that way
resistant to psychic attacks waves and
ability to die isn't his real superpower
his insanity is Deadpool knows he's a
comic book character because he's
absolutely crazy and while his broken
psyche doesn't help much when it comes
to getting a happy ending it's a huge
boon when he faces off against psychics
for example and Deadpool number 69
Deadpool finds himself in a duel at the
telepathic mutant known as the Black
Swan as they fight Swan tries to poke
around in Wade's head to find the
disarmed code for a bomb Deadpool
brought with them unfortunately for Swan
things don't work exactly like he
expected Wade welcome Swan into his mind
which is a savagely insane place that
distracts Swan long enough for Deadpool
to shove the villains head in the
fireplace
Deadpool attempts to defuse the bomb but
it goes off anyway because hey Deadpool
is not great with details
Deadpool's healing powers help fight
against telepathy too and cable and
Deadpool number 8 the x-men timeless
Deadpool to help stop cable who's trying
to create peace by uniting the world's
nations against a common enemy himself
Emma Frost
a psychic use the cerebro to shield the
x-men from cables telepathy but a
Deadpool has an easier way they could
have just had the conversation inside
his brain which is immune to telepathy
thanks to its ever-changing biology
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]